france is reopening to foreign tourists
after the covet 19
pandemic devastated business for more
than a year
the capital paris is enticing visitors
with bargains and
unusually empty museums but as dw's lisa
lewis found out
the city has some tough competition
paris loves its tourists that's the
message these
young multilingual ambassadors are
trying to spread
tourists shouldn't hesitate and just
come to paris we'll help them find their
bearings here at the santro pompidou
and all the other sites paris is such a
pleasant city and there are more and
more of us
to help visitors doing this makes me
happy
up to 500 of them will be deployed this
year in an effort to kick-start tourism
again
after visiting numbers plummeted by
two-thirds last year
but the tourists who normally represent
a large share of the city's visitors
people from asia
and the us might be a bit longer
incoming
we would like everybody to come back to
paris but we are obviously aware that
french and european tourists are likely
to be the first ones back
as it's still easier for them to travel
many hotels are trying to lure in the
locals with special deals
with some luxury establishments offering
discounts
of up to 70 percent but
no offer will convince those already
desperate to get out of the city
this french couple have chosen to go to
higher ground
50 kilometers north of the french
capital
with this pandemic people have
understood that they needed to
disconnect from reality
such special offers aren't necessarily
so important for me
we need to breathe and take a step back
from work
especially as we've all been working
from home for quite a while now
they are not the only ones who feel the
urge to get out of the city
bubble reservations at these cabins have
skyrocketed
it's like people have flipped since the
beginning of the covet 19 crisis and
realized
that they needed nature to reconnect to
who they are
we can't keep up with demand and are now
planning to construct an additional five
cabins
by the end of next year
and yet some might argue this is exactly
the right time
to visit paris or other cities here at
the louvre the world's biggest museum
foreigners make up three quarters of
visitors
but due to covert 19 restrictions
many of these visitors from abroad are
not showing up
that's why you can now even get tickets
at short notice
and visit world famous works of art
almost by yourself what's true for the
louvre is true for other sites in the
french capital
you no longer have to queue for hours
and that
might be the most appealing tourist
attraction of all
you